SECOND BALLOT OR A THIRD.
>> IT'S A RAZOR THIN MAJORITY,
ONE THAT MAY BE TOUGH TO
WRANGLE.
THANK YOU.
>>> HAKEEM JEFFRIES IS VOWING TO
SEEK COMMON GROUND WITH
REPUBLICANS AS HIS PARTY MOVES
INTO THE MINORITY IN THE NEXT
CONGRESS.
EVA McKEND JOINS US LIFE.
THIS IS MARKING A GENERATION
SHIFT FOR THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
AFTER 20 YEARS UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF NANCY PELOSI.
>> Reporter: A GENERATIONAL
SHIFT INDEED.
FOR SO LONG OCTOGENARIANS HAVE
BEEN RUNNING THE SHOW AMONG
HOUSE DEMOCRATS.
BUT JEFFRIES IS NOT NECESSARILY
A FRESH FACE.
IN MANY WAYS THIS HAS BEEN A
LONG TIME IN THE MAKING.
AFTER NEARLY A DECADE ON CAPITOL
HILL, HAKEEM JEFFRIES MAKING
HISTORY AS HOUSE DEMOCRATS
SELECTED HIM AS THE FIRST BLACK
AMERICAN TO LEAD A PARTY IN
CONGRESS.
>> I STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF
SO MANY OTHERS AS WE WORK TO
ADVANCE THE BALL FOR EVERYDAY
AMERICANS AND GET STUFF DONE.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS
DO.
>> Reporter: AT 52, JEFFRIES'
ACCESSION MARKS A GENERATIONAL
CHANGE FROM 82-YEAR-OLD OUTGOING
NANCY PELOSI.
JEFFRIES BECAME DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS CHAIR IN 2019 AND HAS
BEEN KNOWN FOR HIS ADVOCACY
AROUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
>> WE LOOK FORWARD TO FINDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER WITH
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE.
AND WORK WITH THEM WHENEVER
POSSIBLE.
BUT WE WILL ALSO PUSH BACK
AGAINST EXTREMISM WHENEVER
NECESSARY.
>> Reporter: BUT IT WAS HIS ROLE
AS AN IMPEACHMENT MANAGER DURING
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP'S
FIRST IMPEACHMENT TRIAL THAT WAS
AMONG JEFFRIES' MOST HIGH
PROFILE POST.
HIGHLIGHTING HIS BACKGROUND AS A
LAWYER AND HIS PENCHANT FOR
WEAVING IN THE LEGACY OF
P
HIP-HOP.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE AND IF YOU
DON'T KNOW, NOW YOU KNOW.
>> ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS SAID
AREN'T YOU THE CONGRESSMAN THAT
SHOUTED OUT BIGGIE SMALLS ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR TWO YEARS AGO?
YEAH, THAT WAS ME.
NOW I HEAR YOU'RE THE NUMBER
FIVE DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN?
YOU NEVER THOUGHT HIP-HOP WOULD
TAKE IT THIS FAR.
I THINK THAT BIGGY SMALLS,
JAY-Z, IN MANY WAYS CAPTURE THE
ASPIRATIONAL ASPECT OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
>> Reporter: A FORMER LONG-TIME
STAFFER SUGGESTS HE WILL POSE A
FORMIDABLE CHALLENGE TO
REPUBLICANS.
>> HE HAS A MIND LIKE A
COMPUTER.
HE'S BRILLIANT.
HE REMEMBERS EVERY SINGLE DETAIL
OF EVERYTHING FOR ALL OF HIS
SPEECHES WE NEVER WRITE HIS
SPEECHES OUT.
WE PULL TOGETHER THE SUBSTANCE
AND WE HAD GO AND SPEAK FOR 45
MINUTES.
>> Reporter: AND ARGUES HE'S THE
RIGHT MAN FOR THIS MOMENT.
>> IN 2015 I SAID TO HIM, I SAID
YOU'RE GOING TO BE THE NEXT
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE BECAUSE THE
REALITY OF OUR PARTY IS THAT WE
HAVE THIS OLD FACTION THAT WAS
DESTINED TO LEAVE AT SOME POINT
AND HAKEEM WAS THE GUY THAT
COULD BEST ARTICULATE WHAT WE
STOOD FOR.
WE NOW LIVE IN AN ERA THAT
MATTERS MORE THAN OTHER THINGS.
>> Reporter: BUT JEFFRIES HAS TO
CONTEND WITH THE LEFT WING OF
THE PARTY WHO VIEW HIM AS PART
OF THE ESTABLISHMENT.
AND POISED TO TAKE THE MANTLE
WITH A DEMOCRATIC MINORITY.
>> I MAY NOT BE PERFECT BUT I'M
PERFECT FOR YOU.
FOR THOSE WHO CLAIM HE'S NOT
PROGRESSIVE ENOUGH, THERE ARE
LESS PROGRESSIVE PEOPLE WHO
COULD STAND IN HIS STEAD AND TRY
TO OCCUPY HIS SPACE.
HE'S AS PROGRESSIVE A FIGURE AS
IS CAPABLE OF SECURING THE BROAD
BASE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
ORDER TO REPRESENT THEM.
>> Reporter: A BIG QUESTION NOW
IS HOW MUCH WILL THOSE
PROGRESSIVES CHALLENGE HIM.
THEY WERE FRUSTRATED WHEN HE
STARTE